hi I'm Alexander Rose the executive
director at the long now foundation
every month we've been trying to find a
long short a short film that exemplifies
long term thinking they seem to all be
coming in as time lapses at this point
but this month we do have a time lapse
but it is a reverse time lapse this was
done by the folks at the Chicago Field
Museum and it is of their site at the
Museum and it it's several tens of
thousands of years I believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening under Stuart Brandon from
the long now foundation and was that a
mastodon or a mammoth I don't know
either but if it's a mammoth we can now
recreate them with genetic engineering
because their fur has been collected
from the ice and DNA and there is intact
and the idea is to collect some of that
blend it with elephants work it down
till you have a massive down embryo
mammoths embryo bring it to term and a
lady elephant and they're back talk
about running the clock backwards a
couple of months ago was a meeting at UC
Berkeley I forget what the title was but
the subject was applied history
basically addressing the idea that what
if policymakers actually talked to
historians when they made decisions they
talked to economists and get misled they
talk to themselves insurance what they
learned 40 years ago in high school
about history and imagine everything in
terms of it's either Munich or man on
the moon and the want is to be avoided
and the other is to be sought but real
life is seldom like that and so they
make bad decisions because they never
talk to historians so we had a gathering
of historians to think through what
historians might bring to the
policy-making process one of those
speakers will be coming later in the
summer
Frank Gavin talking about six ways to
learn from history and one of them is
here tonight Nils Gilman was trained as
an historian at Cal I've worked with him
not only in that conference but on many
things that we've done a global business
network and what I think's exceptionally
interesting is that when people think
about global business and for that
matter of network they think about the
thing you read about in the paper
the numbers are kept track of and we've
got a sense of things going up or going
down
but it's sort of like overlooking the
billion people who live in squatter
cities in slum
and a few years ago when Rob North came
through and talked about squatter cities
that was like whoa there's a whole
nother civilization scale metabolism
going on out there that we were not
bearing taking into account well Nils
Gilman has something like that for you
tonight please welcome him thank you all
for coming
it's my mic on good okay well in the in
the interests of trying to contextualize
this talk let me talk a little bit about
where I came to these set of ideas from
to begin with my first book which came
out about seven years ago is an
intellectual history of something called
modernization Theory from about the
1940s through the 1970s modernization
theory was kind of dominant framework
that u.s. foreign policy makers and
foreign policy and election was used to
think about what they hoped they could
achieve in what they called the third
world and what I'll today be referring
to as a global South modernization
theory argued that the goal of
development both normatively and
empirically was for other countries to
essentially emulate the historical path
of the United States the idea was that
if we encouraged each individual country
to create a strong public goods
providing welfare providing industrial
demographer democracy this would
eventually create an international
community of like-minded States who
would compete at a business level but
would be bound together in a kind of
actualization of Kant's dream of
perpetual peace so this was kind of a
dominant idea about where development
was going during the first half of the
Cold War now it's pretty obvious that
this vision didn't really pan out all
you have to do is read the newspaper to
know that the global South but much of
the global south anyways continues to
language languish in poverty oppression
and in many cases complex humanitarian
emergencies and basically by the 1990s
when the Cold War was over modernization
at least as an official doctrine had
long since been abandoned in much of the
world
have been replaced by what we now refer
to as structural adjustment programs
which basically focused on downsizing
social support systems in various and
this produced various forms of
semi-permanent marginality relative to
the industrial core of the global north
and that's sort of the situation that I
described in my first book I mean that
arc that history from about the 1940s
through about the 1990s after I was done
writing that book I was still left with
some nagging questions which is what
happens to people after they give up on
the dream of modernization or after the
dream of modernization gives up on them
what happens when people stop thinking
that their states are going to be or at
least are at least trying to provide
them with a framework where they can
work hard keep their noses clean and get
ahead what happens especially when
people confront the reality like that in
the context of an increasingly
globalized economic system I didn't have
any answers to this but this was sort of
the last question I left I was left with
at the end of the book so this was one
set of concerns that came out of my
academic interests the second this this
set of academic questions then merged
with another set of questions which have
really been the focus or a primary focus
of my business consulting practice which
deals with emergent security threats of
one store in another and monitor 360
which is my outfit we look at big
intractable security problems and we try
to find new ways to conceptualize them
to reframe them confront them hopefully
solve them and we ask questions like how
do things like the war on drugs failed
States and guerrilla insurgencies fit
together and how are one of the better
ways to try to conceptualize the
relationships between them and as it
turned out as we were looking across one
incident after another that's been
taking place over the last 15 20 years
we saw that at the root of many of these
issues were trades in illicit
commodities this is true whether it was
blood diamonds or blood oil creating
horrible civil conflicts in Africa it
was true if we looked at the war on
drugs in the way that was providing a
prop for regimes like the Taliban in
Afghanistan back in the 1990s or the
FARC in Colombia or the drug war that's
going on in Mexico right now
we also looked at things like the
sanctions busting scandals that happen
around Iraq and the UN oil-for-food
program prior to the invasion of Iraq in
2003 and we even looked at things like
the evolution of improvised explosive
devices in the combat theaters of Iraq
and Afghanistan and these things have
been the source as many of you probably
know of the majority of coalition
casualties over the last seven years
this is what we refer to as intractable
problems or dilemmas and we feel like
the concept of DD and globalization is
one that really helps us make some sense
of that so these these two streams of
thought came together a couple years ago
in a taut and of course I taught with a
couple of my colleagues at Berkeley
Steve Weber and Jesse gold hammer on the
topic of what I'm not calling deviant
globalization what United all these
different extra legal commodity flows
which underpin so many of these current
emerging security threats was the
unsanctioned circulation of goods and
services that either because of the way
they're produced or because of the way
they're consumed violates someone's
ethical sensibilities that course then
have prompted us to put together a book
on the topics which will be coming out
in the fall which consists of a
collection of essays written mostly by
journalists some academics that
basically look at a variety of
individual instances and I'll be talking
about most of these over the course of
the talk today whether it's you know the
drug trade or sex the sex trade or human
trafficking or the global circulation in
human organs or what have you you know
that series of articles coming out on
that but we also try and I'm going to
provide a summary of the discussion here
today to see whether there are emerging
patterns that we can find across these
different illicit market places across
these deviant market places where there
are certain common structural patterns
and then to think about what it all kind
of means in terms of global politics and
the future of development in the global
south and that's basically what I'm
gonna try to talk about today so first
what is deviant globalization divi
globalization in a word is the
unpleasant underside of globalization
for every legitimate industry that's out
there there's a deviant counterpart
let me just give a few examples so
tourism obviously this is a poster child
for globalization it's something like a
300 billion dollar a year industry
globally three or four hundred dollars
three hundred four hundred billion
dollar a year industry globally and of
course there's a deviant counterpart to
it in the sex tourism industry there's
literally millions of men every year not
a few women also who annually travel to
places like Thailand to Jamaica to the
Netherlands to Cuba to the Philippines
to enjoy sexual pleasures that
presumptively are unavailable to them in
their home countries likewise you look
at the pharmaceutical industry there's a
deviant counterpart in the narcotics
trade drugs illicit drugs are with a
possible exception of oil the single
most globalized business in the world
and they're worth somewhere between a
quarter and half a trillion dollars a
year
waste disposal well it has a deviant
counterpart in what we might call toxic
dumping sometimes illicit Lee but just
as often legally under the guise of
recycling quote-unquote global North
ships literally millions of tons of
toxic waste
batteries chemicals he wastes
end-of-life merchant ships and so on to
the global south where it provides
incomes for many of the people who find
ways to reuse these materials but also
causes obviously massive physical and
environmental insults for the countries
that receive these goods and just to
give you a flavor for what I'm talking
about some of you may have heard of the
Trafigura case which has been going on
for the last four years this involved an
Anglo Dutch company Trafigura which in
the summer of 2006 had a ship cargo full
of extremely toxic wastes and one store
in another that it was trying to get rid
of and it was the ship literally sailed
all around different European ports
trying to find somebody who would take
on these chemicals and they were being
told that they would have to pay
something like a hundred million dollars
to take these chemicals and dispose of
them legally in Europe and needless to
say the company was not too pleased
about having to pay that kind of a rate
and so what they did is they managed to
find a gentleman in Cote d'Ivoire who
set up a shell company in Cote d'Ivoire
and who offered to buy this from them
for a million dollars so then they
sailed this ship down to Abu John and in
the dark of night quite literally
unloaded all this material onto barges
in the port
bhishan and sailed away meanwhile this
fellow took all these stuff and just
simply dumped it into the sewers and
waterways of Abidjan the result was not
only an incredibly horrible smelling
mess apparently the stuff that was in
this cargo hold is the stinkiest stuff
in the world apparently there's
scientists out there who measure
stinkiness and this is the stinkiest
stuff and so the whole plate the whole
city stank but it also was extremely
toxic over a hundred thousand people had
to seek medical assistance and in fact
several dozen people died as a result of
this so that's an example of deviant
waste disposal then there's obviously
the military which takes the form of
arms trafficking arms dealing is
needless to say the you know the
linchpin of many of this terrible
so-called new wars that have been
rolling much of the world from
Afghanistan to Burma all across Africa
these weapons sometimes reach their
recipients through black markets but
more commonly there's a kind of gray
market that's going on here where
militaries from nation-states are
interested in supporting some rebel
group or another usually indirectly and
by the way a lot of these military
officers are interested in making a
dollar on the side and so weapons fall
off the back of a truck and end up in
the hands of some resistance group and I
you know I think most of you will either
remember or certainly have read about
the iran-contra scandal back in the
1980s classic example of this right I
mean the US Congress had said we
couldn't support the Contras directly
and so you know we sold weapons to the
Israelis who shipped them to the
Iranians who gave money the Israelis who
gave the money to the Contras so that
they could fight an insurgency against
the Sandinista regime in Nicaragua
classic kind of case of deviant
globalization a more recent example some
of you may have seen the Nicolas Cage
film The Lord of war which was a
dramatization of the life wealth a loose
loosely based on the life of the
Ukrainian arms dealer Viktor boot who
was probably the biggest single arms
trafficker of the last 15 years got
arrested about a year ago year and a
half ago in um in Thailand and he's been
fighting extradition into the u.s. ever
since then then there's commodities I
mean commodities are obviously a
linchpin of the global economy
circulation of oil
metals Goods and stuff like that but it
also takes deviant forms this is partly
illegally harvested commodities but one
of the things that's worth thinking
about specifically I think is exotic
wildlife tracking which is a much bigger
business trafficking which is a much
bigger business than you might expect
whether it's European wildlife
collectors looking to round out their
collection of Komodo dragons that'll
cost you $30,000 or Chinese men looking
for powdered rhinoceros horn pick me up
that's about $1,500 or San Francisco
interior designers who are looking to
get you a better price on your Brazilian
hardwood floor there's an enormous
industry in harvesting and circulating
many specialty natural goods many of
which are from highly endangered species
or ecosystems and in fact the illicit
commerce this brings up a very important
point about deviant globalization which
is that illicit commerce in otherwise
legal commodities almost certainly
dwarfs the size of the purely illegal
market despite the size of the drug
market so trafficking you know under the
radar of goods like timber or oil or
minerals or diamonds these things are a
huge source of illicit revenues for
people in the global system perhaps the
one of the most disturbing examples of
deviant globalization is deviant
healthcare so with the invention of
cyclosporine in the late 1970s and then
being brought to market in the early
1980s ii sportings the drug that
basically suppresses the amino rejection
response for organ transplants all of a
sudden organ transplantation went from
something that was a very kind of
unusual last last-ditch kind of
procedure in the 1960 to 70s something
that became very very mainstream in the
1980s and 90s I suspect it's probably
almost certainly somebody in this
audience who has a transplanted organ
unfortunately there's a huge gap between
the demand for these organs and the
supply of these organs in most of the
global North organs are supplied from
cadavers and people have to opt in to
being organ donors and the result is
that there's just not enough organs
relatively number of people who are
demanding demanding organs and of course
there's demand for organs has increased
steadily over the years its populations
age as the amount of hypertension
patients age and so there's been steady
increase in demand but there hasn't been
much of an increase in supply the result
is that many people languish for many
years on waiting lists looking for
waiting for you know someone who died in
a motorcycle crash so that they can get
a they can get an organ but there's
another option and as people get
desperate going through dialysis for
many hours three times a week four times
a week it becomes a more and more
reasonable option for them to consider
which is that you can fly today to a
variety of places in the global south
and buy yourself an organ well you don't
have to do it yourself an organ broker
will take care of it for you
and for about a hundred fifty thousand
dollars you can get yourself a new
kidney
well the organ donors themselves don't
get that much they typically go between
one and ten thousand of those one
hundred fifty thousand dollars another
thing that's interesting about the the
global circulation of organs is that it
there's actually several it's actually
not a completely globalized marketplaces
there's several regional marketplaces so
the u.s. the most common place for us
organ donors in this marketplace or
organ recipients in this market place to
go is the Philippines and Brazil
Philippines in Brazil they actually
source their organs locally there are
local donors mostly for the for the
Europeans the most popular places are
Istanbul in South Africa in South Africa
they mostly go to they mostly actually
fly in Brazilians to be organ donors
because Europeans are afraid of getting
African organs ostensibly because of HIV
although there may be other reasons
there in East Asia it's a completely
different marketplace the focus there is
there's a lot of organ transplant
facilities in South Asia many in India
specifically and they get a lot of their
organs locally there's also a lot of
Chinese and Japanese businessmen who go
to the Philippines like Americans do to
get these organs so there's a complex
global network of these organ dealers
supplying and demanding these organs
well there's also the software industry
obviously another big globalized
industry I'll be talking about this a
little bit more later but the obvious
deviant counterpart to the software
industry is malware industry malware
stands for malicious software this is
Trojans viruses things that take over
your computer and either exfiltrate data
steal your personal information or turn
your computer into a zombie part of a
botnet so they can run spam denial of
service attacks and so on
then there's immigration immigration and
human trafficking an estimated three or
four million people annually illegally
immigrate from one country to another at
least without formal license from one
country to another and these movements
are facilitated by a huge network of
brokers and logistics professionals who
for a fee will help move you from
wherever you want to go to wherever else
you want to go so for example today
people pay between thirty thousand and
seventy five thousand dollars to be
moved from China to the United States
usually through Mexico these days they
were coming through Europe took a couple
of years ago but Mexico is the main
transition point some of the Mexican
drug cartels have sort of diversified
their business by getting into the human
trafficking thing if you want to get
from Cuba to the US that will cost you
about ten thousand dollars which is
actually the same price that a gang of
Iraqis was charging Iraqis in 2007 and
2008 was the height of the civil war in
Iraq to be transported from Baghdad to
Great Britain so there's again all sorts
of global networks brokered by brokered
by people who are willing to make these
things happen and finally perhaps most
importantly there's the deviant finance
industry otherwise known as money
laundering the reason why this might be
the most important industry is this is
the industry that allows all of these
other guys who are doing this illicit
stuff to bring their money back into the
daylight so basically the size of the
deviant finance industry is at least
equal to all the other deviant
industries put together now I'll mention
this a little bit later one needs to be
skeptical when one hears about numbers
but estimates of the size of the
money-laundering industry globally
ranged from between one and a half and
five trillion dollars annually so that's
between four and twelve percent of GDP
globally so it's a pretty it's a pretty
significant business now this is not an
exhaustive list of deviant industries I
should note there are many other illicit
market places most of which are
thoroughly globalized another one that I
just learned about recently
is that the third-largest illicit
marketplace in terms of cash trans cash
transfers and the third after after
drugs and human trafficking is the
stolen art market there it's worth an
estimated ten billion dollars a year and
in fact there are whole law firms in the
United States the UK and in France whose
businesses focused exclusively on
discreetly arranging the necessary
ransoms to get your stolen art back so
and again you know these guys don't want
to advertise what they're actually or
publicized what they're paying for these
things you need to look at the numbers
skeptically but it's a big big problem
in addition as I've kind of pointed out
with some of these examples a lot of
these businesses are sort of overlapping
and interdigitated and just there's a
great essay in the book that's coming
out by Johnny Steinberg a South African
journalists talking about the illicit
abalone business in South Africa's
abalone is a large tasty snail and sea
snail and it turns out that it's
particularly considered a delicacy in in
South China if you guys have had you've
probably had it at dim sum places and
unsurprisingly there for the you know
abalone furthermore is a fairly tightly
controlled it's easy to over fish
abalone and so it's a fairly tightly
controlled Fisheries and in South Africa
it indeed is controlled but not so much
by the state but rather by Chinese Triad
gangsters who basically controlled the
abalone trade between South Africa and
Guangzhou what's really interesting
about this is that it's not just at than
in the illicit abalone business but the
way they pay for their abalone to the
people who are harvesting the stuff in
South Africa's they pay them in kind
with crystal meth which is produced in
China so there's abalone going out going
out from South Africa and the container
comes back filled with crystal meth
which then fuels the huge drug problem
in in many of the townships and slums
around Johannesburg and Cape Town that
in a nutshell is what deviant
globalization is all about so the main
thing I want to leave you with from this
part of the presentation is that Divi
globalization is not a marginal
phenomenon it's a huge phenomenon and by
all indications its rapidly growing
want to give you a couple examples of
some of the ways in which we know that
it's growing and that these numbers also
tell us a little bit about the nature of
the trade so let me talk about cocaine
prices this is in kilo equivalent so in
1997 a kilo kilo equivalent of cocaine
at the farm door gate in Peru cost about
$650 that's dropped to about $250 a few
years ago these numbers by the way all
come from the UN Office for Drug Control
then after it gets shipped for
processing to Colombia it costs about a
thousand dollars then once it's
important into the United States it
costs about fifteen thousand dollars now
again all these numbers are continually
dropping over time once it's wholesaled
in the United States goes up again to
about $21,000 and finally at the retail
street price of a kilo of cocaine so
once it's broken up into grams size
packages it codes for about one hundred
and seven thousand dollars these are two
thousand five prices but you can see the
numbers are generally declining over
time now most of you may not be
economists but generally speaking when
prices are declining and demand is
steady as we had to assume it probably
is for a commodity like this that
generally means the demand that supply
is increasing right the other thing that
I'd point out is really really important
to recognize is look at where the profit
margin is highest it's specifically at
the at the stage of importation now why
is that
that is because that is where there's
the most pressure on the supply chain
from there from the narcotics regulators
the DEA so the narcotics regulators they
think they're in the drug eradication
business they're actually in the drug
regulation business and by increasing
the risk for the people who are
importing this stuff in they actually
increase the ability of those who stay
in the business to demand premium prices
and actually raise the profit margins
for the people who managed to survive in
the business so if you're able to if
you're able to control that part of the
business by say corrupting a border
agent and there's been 80 border agents
in the last three years in the US just
on the US side of the border that have
been convicted of corruption of one sort
or another then you can make fourteen
hundred percent profit margins now some
of you may not be businesspeople but
almost every business person in the
world would kill for a business with
those
the margins and in fact these guys do
another piece of data that is useful for
sort of getting a sense of the growth of
this is the growth of malware so these
are new malicious code signatures and
new variants of malware in terms of
thousands of cases again this data is
collected by one of the leading
antivirus software companies Symantec
and you can see between 2003 and 2009
there's been about two hundred percent a
year annual growth in the number of
malware cases now there's a lot of stuff
that's going on with this but a big part
of this is where these malware cases are
originating from and increasingly they
are originating from the global south
that's directly correlated to the fact
that internet adoption is increasing
rapidly in the global south if there's
one thing that's almost an iron law is
that within 6 to 18 months of a country
getting big fat broad win broadband
access it is likely to emerge as a new
hotbed of hacking now to paraphrase uh
Nicholas Negroponte who runs the Media
Lab at MIT or we used to run the Media
Lab at MIT a laptop for every child
means a hacker in every Hut now I could
proceed with some more examples but I
think you get the point and actually I
tend to be pretty skeptical of a lot of
the statistics we hear about deviant
globalization mainly because everybody
who's involved in this has an incentive
to lie about the size of these things
these last two sets of statistics
cocaine prices and and malware
signatures these are things where the
criminals have to come out in the open
to do their business so you have some
confidence that these numbers are
probably pretty accurate but a lot of
the other numbers are probably not
particularly reliable on the one hand
the deviant industries themselves do
everything they can to remain out of
sight of state authorities or anybody
else who's really trying to measure on a
consistent basis what they're up to
on the other hand most of the state
organizations that are in charge or
supposed to be in charge of paying
attention to this stuff have a vested
interest both in exaggerating the scale
of the phenomenon
and in exaggerating the scale their
success against the phenomenon so all in
all there's not a lot of confidence in
the statistics because deviant
globalization takes place sort of in the
shadows of the global economy and
outside the purview of the state
generally speaking the best way to try
to get your head around this problem is
to look at we might call ethnographic
accounts and some of this is done by
journalism it's done by academics sort
of a mix and if you see the book it
reflects that one but there's a series
of books that I register in the last
couple of years that have really
illuminated this phenomenon for me one
is Gomorrah by the Italian the Italian
writer Roberto Saviano which has also
been made into a great movie that I
recommend if you haven't seen about the
way that Neapolitan mob has infiltrated
every aspect of daily life in that part
of Italy
then there's the snakehead by Patric rad
and Keef which is a brilliant account of
the dynamics of illegal Chinese
immigration the new yorker which is
currently edited by David Remnick who
cut his teeth on this twenty years ago
when he wrote a book on the collapse of
the Soviet Union which was a hotbed of
stage one deviant globalization he's
been having a whole series of writers do
really interesting stuff one of the best
pieces that I've read recently is by
Rafi katchadorian on the illegal timber
trade in Siberia and finally I have to
recommend Carolyn nordstrom's book
global outlaws which is sort of an
ethnographic account of what the war
economy of angola is like and how it
actually works it's it's a brilliant
book so these are the kinds of sources
that I've used to really get my head
around this stuff in addition to doing a
lot of interviews with people who are
participating in these kinds of in these
kinds of activities so what makes
deviant globalization possible in a word
we do you do I do the essence of devian
globalization is moral arbitrage now let
me unpack that emile durkheim the French
sociologist observed a long time ago
that societies are to a large extent
defined and made up made up of and
defined by their taboos that is by what
they prohibit either morally or in the
case of modern societies legally but in
iliza world economy the functional
affective taboos and prohibitions is not
necessarily so much as to reduce demand
so much as it is to reduce supply in
particular locations which in turn
creates market opportunities
moreover the prohibitions or their
effective enforcement varies
tremendously from one locale to another
creating price gaps between different
locations now taking advantage of these
kinds of price differences for a given
commodity between two different market
places represents exactly what
economists refer to as an arbitrage
opportunity that is an opportunity to
make a market between two places where
the prices aren't on aren't aligned and
this is precisely what deviant
entrepreneurs are doing with respect to
deviant commodities they're connecting
suppliers in one lightly regulated or
controlled marketplace to customers in a
different more heavily controlled or in
this expensive marketplace sometimes
that means moving the commodities from
the commodities closer to the consumers
drugs or what-have-you
other times that means moving the cut
the consumer closer to the products sex
tourism the Oregon trade and so on state
regulations and here's the key point
state regulations which embody the moral
inhibitions of the people they represent
or at least some of the more inhibitions
of some of the people they represent are
the things that create the opportunities
for the deviant entrepreneurs sex
tourism only exists because people can't
get that kind of sex at home drug
dealing makes the highest profits
precisely where people decide to put
them the regulator's decide to put the
most pressure or consider cigarettes and
booze right there's huge black markets
and cigarettes and booze and these
markets grow in very statistically
measurable ways every time you increase
the prices the taxes on cigarettes and
booze so there's huge businesses in
Eastern Europe
I mean cigarettes in Europe costs seven
eight dollars a pack they cost about 40
cents to produce and so there's huge
cigarette smuggling businesses based
mostly in the Balkans which are just
outside the European Union that
basically supply something between 15
and 30% of cigarettes to Western Europe
same exact thing is going on in the
Western Hemisphere cigarette smuggling
is a hotbed of is one of the key
industries in the tri border area
between Brazil Argentina and
in South America and a lot of these
cigarettes end up on the shelves here in
San Francisco so here's a key point it's
it's our moral inhibitions during our
attempt to enforce them and inevitably
enforce them unevenly that creates the
opportunities for devian entrepreneurs
to make the money that they do all right
now I want to make a couple of other
points about the structure of this trade
DB globalization is not identical to
illicit trade what really defines
deviant globalization is not so much
whether it's legal or illegal as what
you might refer to as the yuck factor
let me give you an example of that
perfectly legal activity which
definitely is deviant globalization
until 2008 the age of consent in Canada
was 14 it was only raised to 18 a couple
of years ago when the story that I'm
about to tell became a scandal and in
Canada turned out that 2005 2006 2007
there were all these men primarily in
border states in the United States
Minnesota and Michigan New York who were
using chat rooms to meet 15 14 year-old
girls from Canada online and arranged
assignation when they would go meet them
in hotel rooms in Toronto or Montreal or
what-have-you in in in Canada this was
obviously a way of getting around the
underage sex laws in the United States
and it was all perfectly legal but also
perfectly deviant same thing is going on
right now now that that's changed now
that they've changed the laws in Canada
but the same thing is going on right now
in the heart of Europe so right now the
age of consent for paid sexual relations
in Switzerland is 16 in Italy in France
it's 18 and in Germany is 21 well
unsurprisingly Switzerland
has emerged as you know basically an
entrepeneur you know men who like sex
with underage girls or a young girls I
should say it's become a magnet for it
and this is all over the newspapers in
in France the second thing I'd say is
that deviant globalization is not
identical to the informal economy we
shouldn't confuse it with
disorganization
yes it's run out off the books an
outside government oversight but most
evening globalization enterprises most
evening enterprise of the storm
describing or anything but mom-and-pop
shops in fact most of the participants
in deviant globalization operate in
large complex and carefully managed
organizations run by ruthless
entrepreneurs whose basic business
strategies would be familiar to any
reader of the Harvard Business Review
the big guys are constantly trying to
increase their market share they try to
be number one or number two and every
market they enter while the little guys
seek niche differentiation let's say
they seek monopolies and work out
strategies for creating what you might
call barriers to entry they develop they
develop channel strategies so that once
they have once they built a pipe for
moving one kind of illicit commodity why
not pump all sorts of other illicit
commodities so those gangsters and the
Balkans who started out by being
cigarette smugglers during the 1990s as
a way brand and then became sanctions
Buster's during the sanctions against
Serbia and now become the primary
traffickers of women for for sexual
slavery in Western Europe they're you
know taking poor women out of the
villages of Eastern Europe and Russia
and bringing them across the border to
serve in brothels and in Western Europe
in the European Union
and finally they often leverage the
latest in information technology and
there's a story possibly apocryphal but
telling nonetheless that in I believe
was 1999 or 2000 a Colombian drug lords
house was raided and they found in his
basement a mainframe an IBM mainframe
that was being used to run the complex
spreadsheet and future forecasting for
his entire business now I don't know
where he got a consultant to run this
thing I guess he wasn't the guy running
it himself
but somehow I managed to get this thing
run to run his very complex business
now I don't want to exaggerate this
there's a lot of businesses a lot of
deviant businesses are not necessarily
run with profit maximization as their
exclusive focus political power prestige
business stability business continuity
these are often you know imperative
things anybody has to just watch the TV
show The Wire you can see how much
business continuity tends to be
something that's top of mind for these
guys but at the same time the same thing
exact same exact thing is true of
aboveboard businesses you know the
notion that all businesses are profit
maximum maximizing to the exclusion of
everything else is a complete lie
everybody knows that people make
trade-offs about you know work-life
balance about you know what businesses
they want to go into what kinds of
clients and customers they want to
pursue these things are not governed
just by profit motive motives but all
sorts of other kinds of things all right
so that in a nutshell is what deviant
globalization is what I'd like to do
next is talk a little bit about what
deviant globalization means and I have
two propositions each of which are met
as a provocation the first thing I'd
like to say is that deviant
globalization is development let me
start by reading you a quote from Milton
Friedman which i think is quite telling
them Friedman would be our gentlemen
here on the left
Milton Friedman said the black market
was a way of getting this is a quote the
black market was a way of getting around
government controls it was a way of
enabling the free market to work it was
a way of opening up enabling people now
I'll confess that quoting Milton
Friedman in this way in this context is
a little bit cheeky but Milton funcle'
Milty is making a very important point
for us which is the deviant
globalization is not necessarily all bad
news if you like entrepreneurship if you
like innovation then you've got to love
deviant globalization the guys who
organized the markets of deviant
globalization are in many case brilliant
innovators they're constantly building
new businesses they know how to thrive
amid the chaos of contemporary
capitalism all the cliches you read
about radical innovation disruptive
innovation apply in spades to deviant
global deviant enterprises second and
just as importantly deviant
globalization represents an extremely
significant flow of money and resources
from the global north to the global
south there's a large amount of
resources that come this way almost
certainly several orders of magnitude
bigger than the foreign a that's flows
from the global north of the global
South almost certainly an order of
magnitude bigger than the remittances
that flow from the global north of the
global south this is a major way of
bringing wealth from the global north to
the global south would this suggest what
these two ideas suggest is that in a
peculiar way D being globalization is
enabling precisely the sorts of
grassroots empowerment and non
dependency that dependency theorists and
World Bank types have been calling for
for the last 60 years in development let
me give you another example to kind of
frame this for you there was an article
in the Atlantic Monthly that appeared in
December by Phil Caputo where he noted
that the Mexican narcotics industry
currently directly employs 400,000
people directly employs four and a
thousand people that's more than the
finance industry that's more than the
oil industry that's more in fact in
every single industry except for tourism
and agriculture this is a major major
part of the Mexican economy
my colleague Jessie Goldhammer who's the
co-editor of the book was in this in
Mexico a couple years ago he's in a
small village in Oaxaca and he noticed
that everybody in this village had a
brand new house a color TV and a
satellite dish he's a little bit
surprised by this he seemed to be poor
peasants who were just you know farming
corn and whatnot and he started asking
some questions about where all this
stuff came from and he at first got a
lot of cold stares not a lot of answers
then some hemming and hawing about
remittances and finally he was told to
shut up and stop asking questions this
is a way that people can get rich or at
least stop being as poor as they were
before and this is also fully recognized
by many of the states where this stuff
is going on there's a number of states
that have embraced deviant globalization
as an explicit developmental strategy
for themselves probably the most obvious
and conspicuous example is the way that
sex tourism is actively encouraged by a
number of states in Southeast Asia and
there's a there's sort of a
demonstration effect there Thailand
basically became a global entrepreneur
sex in the 1960s when it basically
offered to be the host for American
soldiers on rest and recreation from the
Vietnam War was RNR or what was also
known as I and I intercourse and
intoxication and this absolutely helped
jumpstart the the Thai economy a lot of
money came in I mean obviously a lot of
it was related to military procurement
and spending in other ways from the US
from the US but it was a very
significant source of revenue and many
countries that are neighboring Thailand
are today emulating that exact same
pattern whether it's Cambodia or the
Philippines these guys see themselves
very much as a way see you know
encouraging or at least tacitly putting
up with sex tourism as a way to
jumpstart economic development and in
some ways you know this is not that
different in kind from the way many
third-world countries almost all third
world countries are perfectly happy to
accept the polluting factory as a way of
attracting investment in jump-starting
growth you know just the same way you
know it's basically a question of
whether you want to accept physical
pollution or a kind of social and moral
pollution in order to jumpstart your
growth
so beyond the states in question D being
globalization also represents the
personal enrichment strategy for those
who participate in the trade now I don't
want to say that coercion is not part of
the equation
in many cases certainly is but in the
majority of cases people who sell their
organs or become drug mules or decide to
have sex with filthy middle-aged
foreigners aren't doing it because
they're forest but are doing it because
it's the fastest best or easiest way to
make a dollar and it's better than
staying back in the village so from that
perspective deviant globalization can be
seen as a kind of survival strategies of
the week and to say this again is not to
deny the awfulness of the exploitation
and the oppressiveness that in many
cases deviant globalization represents
for the line workers within deviant
deviant enterprises but it's simply to
recognize that with rare exceptions most
of the participants child prostitutes
aside have some degree of agency in this
becoming a wildlife smuggler or a drug
runner or an organ donor is a choice
it's not very pleasant choice but are
you really so sure that it's a bet it's
a worse choice than becoming a coal
miner in China every week on average
more people die coal mining in China and
then died in that mining accident in
West Virginia last week so let me step
back now and talk a little bit about
what the background the back story to
deviant globalization is and this
returns me to the theme I started with
my dissertation which I then turned into
a book which was about the failure of
what I in that book referred to as high
modernist development schemes now
getting into high modernist development
is a topic for another day but I have to
provide a brief thumbnail of it in order
to make this make make sense here so
high modernism refers to a vision of
economic development as a process that
governments spearhead on behalf of their
populations as a whole and that aims to
create a broadly inclusive set of public
goods around health security education
health care so on now from the point of
view of the global South the Cold War
was from one perspective a debate about
whether communist
or liberal capitalism offered better
prospects for building precisely such
prosperous public goods providing
welfare states now diverse economic
strategies as we all know were attempted
to we're tried in order to realize this
dream collective ownership of the means
of production in communist countries
less a fair import substitution
industrialization export-led growth and
diverse political programs went along
with this
but what almost all of these strategies
had in common with a few exceptions in
East Asia is that they failed communism
of course failed most spectacularly but
again except for a few countries in the
Pacific Rim capitalism didn't do much
better for most of those countries
during most of this period not in terms
of headline growth not in terms of
poverty reduction not in terms of most
measures of human development is
measured by the United Nations
now when communism died in 1989 what
died was not just the particular
collectivist economic system in
authoritarian politics of the Soviet
Union its satellites cremated along with
that corpse was the broadly public civic
minded notion of development as the
central defining responsibility of the
post-colonial state what arose instead
in the 1990s late 1980s and early 1990s
was what came to be known as the
Washington Consensus now the Washington
Consensus represented the dominant
neoliberal economic program for the
global south during the 1990s as
promoted by the IMF in the US government
and the Harvard economist Dani Rodrik
has defined it this way says stabilize
privatized and liberalized became the
mantra of a generation of technocrats
who cut their teeth in the developing
world and of the political leaders they
counseled wasn't hard to understand why
they this particular view of what the
state shouldn't shouldn't be doing made
sense it was not hard to point to the
undeniable corruption the inefficiency
the rent-seeking and predatory behavior
of many post-colonial states in the
global south and neoliberalism had a
solution that definitely addressed those
problems it sought to dismantle these
states by slashing public bureaucracies
foreign aid trade barriers and so on and
where such programs were successfully
imposed which included almost all of
Latin America much of
South Asia much of Africa it led to what
might in a nutshell be called the
hollowing out of the state what I mean
by hollowing out is that you still have
in these places the physical and
institutional infrastructure of a state
you still have the Capitol building you
still have Representatives that go to
the European Union you still have a
Constitution that says that this that
and the next thing is supposed to go on
but the actual capacity of those states
to deliver anything like what they had
been saying to their people they were
supposed to be delivering whether they
were delivering and I was another story
the actual capacity to deliver those
things really went away in a way that
was a real signal difference from the
way things were being run from the 1950s
through the 1980s and most of these
states and the post-war post Cold War
hauling out of these states had two
really critical results both of which
are you can't understand why he would
glow ization happen without
understanding these two results the
first one is the deviant globalization
signal unmistakably these cut to the
individuals in these countries that Your
Honor on the end of the promise of state
building and building states to provide
public goods or the rather perhaps more
accurately the revelation that those
promises had always been empty meant
that people had to strike out on their
own and the result was a global
unleashing of what we might call
survival entrepreneurship throughout the
global south and above all in the former
communist states which had previously
lacked any legal outlets for that kind
of that kind of behavior and you know
here it's again I mentioned David
Remnick cutting his teeth on the history
of the late Soviet Union and the
economic system that was going on there
there's a reason why Eastern Europe
emerged as the real hotbed an epicenter
of deviant globalization in the 1990s
and that's because the only people who
really had entrepreneurial skills in the
late 1980s who were able to develop them
in communist regime were people who were
explicitly doing things that were
illegal you had to already be an amoral
person willing to flout the laws of the
state in order to develop the kinds of
entrepreneurial skills that would be
absolutely required in the you know post
shock therapy post neoliberal post
Washington Consensus versions of the
states that they were gonna operate in
so it was absolutely inevitable and you
read REM Nick's book from 1991 he spells
it out
it's absolutely Nevitt of all that the
people
are gonna take over the economies in
these places are people who are
criminals so that's at the elite level
at the grassroots level people have the
same kinds of choices to make the
economies were collapsing and people did
what they had to do to survive if that
meant you know becoming sex workers or
organ sellers or narcotics purveyors or
wildlife smugglers and they did that
this is what they had to do to survive
and so they did and the second and
equally important impact of the
hollowing out of states at the end of
the Cold War was it largely dismantled
the regulatory capacity of states in the
global south so in other words tossed
out with the statist baby was much of
the practical capacity to enforce any
kind of border control or other kinds of
legal regimes this to liberated the
forces of globalization obviously you
know and it basically turned the entire
global south into a Smuggler's paradise
this borderless world of the global
South was in many ways is in many ways a
kind of return to the pre-modern order
of fragmented sovereignties
jurisdictional ambiguities localized
governance and there's still a state
that's sitting there but those guys in
many cases are not people who are
running anything that actually matters
on the ground in most places in the
global south so what is all this add up
to well from one perspective devian
globalization can be seen as the failure
of modernization and development but
from another perspective it can be seen
as not as the failure of development as
I said but rather as actually existing
development
I used that phrase carefully actually
existing development some of you may
remember is meant to be an ironic echo
of the old Soviet phrase that the Soviet
Union represented actually existing
socialism this was of course meant as a
put-down to all those kind of Western
socialists who said no no that's a
perverted version of socialism that's
not real socialism we have a different
vision of it and the Soviet said no no
no we have actually existing socialism
don't listen to what all those you know
soft-headed liberals in the West who
think they're socialists actually think
socialism means so likewise equating
deviant globalization with actually
existing development is meant as an
invitation to judge development not by
the vision statements put forth by the
World Bank or the IMF or the
it's foundation but rather by its actual
results just as actually existing
socialism represents a kind of perverse
realization of socialism promise of
equality so deviant globalization
represents a kind of perverse
realization of capitalism's promise of
personal liberty to the same extent that
Soviet oppression represented and told
us something very fundamental and very
disturbing about the dream of socialism
deviant globalization tells us something
very fundamental and very disturbing
about the dream of capitalism simply put
deviant globalization is what you get
when you combine massive socio-economic
inequality moral lumpiness across a
global landscape and the technologies of
globalization to bring all that together
what that enables is the rapid movement
of people and goods and none of these
elements are likely to be reversed over
time barring some really unexpected
exogenous shock and so I would summarize
by saying deviant globalization is not a
correctable aberration it's not some you
know exception to the rule of
globalization it's not a marginal
feature of the system it is the system
the second major proposition excuse me
the second major proposition I'd like to
make about why devian globalization
matters is the D being globalization is
creating a new class of political actors
whose geopolitical importance is only
likely to grow when the underlying
resource streams that they're in control
of just like the classic high modernist
state that I was talking about earlier
was supposed to create a certain class
of actors namely a welfare public goods
providing state giving globalization is
creating a different class of
geopolitical actors what my friend John
rabe refers to and his blog as quote
unquote global guerrillas now in what
sense are people like the people in this
picture by the way these are guerrillas
mend movement for the emancipation of
the Nigerian Delta they steal oil
basically for or I shouldn't say steal
they take the oil that's being pumped
out of their their swamp by Western oil
companies and hold it for ransom or
threaten to blow up those pipelines if
the oil companies won't pay them more
money and so on
then what sense are these guys political
actors well
as we seen Debian entrepreneurs are
controlling large and growing swaths of
the global economy and they have this
control basically outside the purview of
the state the state's you know have
estimates of how big they are but have
no control over no ability to they can
sort of shape the flows but they can't
really dictate the size or dictate
exactly who's going to be running these
things there's no sort of very efficient
regulatory system for deviant
globalization these actors also because
they work in extra legal marketplaces
wield a not insignificant quota of
violence and force and that's sort of an
occupational hazard if you're gonna run
in that extra legal business you got to
be able to adjudicate contracts and the
courts aren't going to help you there
and finally these DBA offerors and this
is what's really interesting
many of these deviant entrepreneurs are
beginning to provide privatized versions
of the same kinds of political goods
that states used to say they were in the
business of providing now let me explain
what that means so they these private
actors are beginning to provide things
like health clinics infrastructure
personal security justice of a rough
sort to the local communities in which
they operate they build parks they build
medical clinics they sometimes even
build schools now these are not things
that are open to the public they're open
to their particular constituents the
children of the people who are in their
businesses these are all company towns
if you will there's no such thing as
public goods for these guys but they are
providing the kinds of goods that create
political loyalties in the consumers of
these goods so if you're getting your
clinic and your road and your job from
guys like this are you gonna be more
loyal to these guys or to the robber
barons up in Abuja it's pretty clear
where your loyalties are gonna lie now
this thing I want to emphasize is that
these guys are not nice people generally
speaking it's important to recognize
that these guys these political
entrepreneurs are both a cause and an
effect of state hollowing out and
they're thus a threat to the state as
classically understood but they're
resolutely not revolutionary actors like
chicken borrower the Ayatollah Khomeini
revolutionary actors sought to capture
the state they wanted to control the
state because they wanted to deliver
those kinds of goods and services the
public goods and services I was
referring to earlier to their
constituents they had a very different
kind of agenda these guys people like
these two diego ferdinand de maria who
is a big drug dealer in colombia more
viktor boot and the arms dealer i
referred to earlier he's the guy on the
right these are much more typical to
sort of counter status actors the
deviant globalization produces but what
they don't want to do is they don't want
to take over the state i mean why would
you want to take over the state doesn't
it doesn't have any very good functions
you have to attend all sorts of boring
meetings in Washington and New York and
then you also have to provide services
to people you don't care about they'd
much rather provide services to the
people who are part of their communities
as they define them and here I'm
thinking a people of groups's like the
Mahdi Army in in Baghdad or the first
command of the capital which is a prison
gang in in Brazil or the ndrangheta in
in Italy the Roberto Saviano writes
about en and Gomorrah or the drug
cartels in Mexico these guys are all
challenging the state de facto but
except when they're directly challenged
by the state they don't go after the
state now they do sometimes get into
direct conflicts with a state but it's
only usually when the state initiates
the conflict so a couple of years ago
the first command of the Capitol shut
down South Paulo for three days
completely shut down by staging attacks
against police stations and the reason
they did that was because the government
had decided they were gonna try to break
up the communications network that the
drug kingpins were all in jail were
putting together they were seizing all
the cell phones who were using a
coordinate stuff so these guys ordered a
basically a hit taken out on the state
and for three days Sao Paulo state was
shut down in Sao Paulo stage should be
noted has a quarter of all the
industrial production of South America
so they basically shut down a quarter of
South America for three days and but
this was because the state initiated the
the conflict likewise the bloodbath is
currently taking place in northern
Mexico as a direct result of the new
president coming in in late 2006 and
saying you know stop there was a lot of
violence going on between the drug gangs
competing over turf but there wasn't a
lot of violence directed at citizens the
reason why things like what happened in
see that Juarez a couple in January
where a party full of teenagers was
just machine-gun for no reason is that
these gangsters we're trying to tell the
government that if you keep messing with
us we're gonna start taking it out on
your constituents so it's only in those
contexts that these guys usually
directly confront the state they prefer
rather to sort of just undermine the
state create make the state be weak to
carve out zones of autonomy for
themselves so they can run their
businesses make their money and they're
not generally interested in directly
undermining the state and yet de facto
they end up functionally sapping the
capacity the legitimacy of the state
because they're replacing the state de
facto functionally okay this is a
picture from sub paulo by the way
actually yeah this is sub paulo you'll
notice by the way that um that big pool
with swimming lanes is not enough these
guys each need to have their own pool on
their balconies
these guys are alright though what I'd
like to conclude where there's some
thoughts about what all this tells us
about the future of the world's economic
system the world political system
I think devian globalization has
basically two really interesting things
to tell us about that and it contradicts
the two most dominant narratives about
the global south that have predominated
in American foreign policy thinking and
public discourse over the last 15 or 20
years the first one of those discourses
is the kind of liberal view put forward
by people like Tom Friedman or back in
the 1990s Francis Fukuyama that said
that we were headed for that modernist
vision of liberal States they said we're
going to have economic growth the
world's going to become flat everybody's
going to get rich it's going to be great
and we're gonna actually end up with
this world this content vision of
perpetual peace so this sort of liberal
dream of what international relations
can become is one dominant narrative now
it's pretty obvious the ways in which
deviant globalization challenges that
particular narrative you know rather
than creating a flat world what we've
seen is the deviant entrepreneurs are
actually interested in creating a lumpy
world that create arbitrage
opportunities that they can then turn
into huge profits for themselves deviant
globalization is not creating or at
globalization in general and therefore
deviant globalization is not creating a
flat world but rather creating a
with huge disparities where there are
actors like the mend or like the annetta
that are perfectly happy with that state
of affairs and are perfectly happy to
challenge states and tacit ways rather
than directly states are withering away
hollowing out in the global south the
notion that these guys are going to be
co-equal partners in some international
comedy of high capacity liberal states
all of which are equally functional is
something like a bad joke so that's
probably pretty obvious way in which
deviant globalization contradicts one
kind of conventional wisdom about the
global south
but I think what's more interesting
actually is the way that deviant
globalization contradicts a different
narrative about the global south and
that's a much more dystopian narrative
that's been put forward by a number of
people and this usually goes under the
you know the the person who really
kicked off this rhetoric back in the
1990s was the journalist Robert Kaplan
in an essay that appeared in the
Atlantic called the coming anarchy and
he basically depicted a world a future
where there were two worlds there was
the zone of order the global north where
things were going to be great I mean the
Cold War was over
we weren't gonna have to worry about the
bomb coming down on our head and we were
all gonna get rich we're gonna have lots
of trade but then there was the other
world the zone of Anarchy which was of
course most of the world and here was a
situation of failed and collapsing
states of horrible new diseases of
terrorists of new wars of genocides and
for much of the 1990s caplet looked like
a visionary people saw what happened in
the Balkans people saw what happened in
Rwanda and the combination of Kaplan's
vision seemed to take place on September
11th 2001 when terrorists sitting in one
of these zones of Anarchy type places in
Afghanistan managed to successfully plan
and launch an attack which killed 3,000
people in Washington or close to 3,000
people in Washington and New York City
but I think deviant globalization has
something important to challenge in this
vision and this might seem surprising
because because the point about devian
globalization is that this is not about
disorder it's actually very much an
orderly
that deviant globalization creates it's
just not a liberal order that it's
creating it's creating a very illiberal
order but these are places the places
that from the point of view of
Washington or London look like uncover
knowns or in fact usually very governed
they're just not governed by States or
the kinds of people that we like they're
governed by people who have you know
narrow minded intra and narrow minded
interests they don't have a notion of
the public they have what sometimes gets
called traditional values but are really
sort of B'nai 'td backward horrible
prejudices of one store in another but
these are people who are providing order
for their communities and I mean I was
just having conversation with Stuart
before this before this talk about
Somalia northern Somalia so-called
Puntland is in many ways one of the
better off places in in in Africa you
know they have a they have a thriving
business piracy they have a very good
infrastructure system the very dense
cellphone network is probably better
than the coverage we get in the 101 you
know they have people who provide order
and justice you know it's not very
pleasant if you're a woman it's not very
pleasant for an adulterer and it's not
very pleasant if you don't want to
worship Muhammad but you know those
things aside there's a certain order
there for sure and it's wrong to think
of these places as a zone of anarchy or
a zone of disorder or a failed state
these are not failed States failed
States the very concept of a failed
state falsely implies that the that the
normative order that everybody in the
world wants to aspire to is a liberal
state like something Max Weber thought
up or the Westphalian type of state
that's been the dominant model that most
Western states have striven after for
the last 150 years but that's not what
these guys want and they're providing a
very different kind of order and they're
learning to live in a world outside
liberal States so finally what can we do
about all this well I think again there
might be a couple of choices we often
hear one option that we sometimes hear
is that we simply need to shut
globalization down this stuff is
horrible and that when we just do is is
n globalization go back to
autonomous nation states sometimes you
hear the Porto Alegre crowd they fly in
annually and complain about about jet
setters and they call for capitalism to
be restrained and in essence for the
plan to return to a kind of long-lost
ideal of unitary homogeneous
nation-states several things to be said
about this first of all well I actually
kind of like globalization I like
traveling I like the things that it
brings me both culturally economically
and so on but quite a set of my personal
preferences this is not going to work
and why isn't it going to work well what
if we just learned about devian
globalisation deviant globalization the
deviant entrepreneurs love it when
people put up trade barriers that is how
they make a profit so the more people
try to pull back from globalization the
more this is actually going to create an
opportunity for exactly the deviant
entrepreneurs to be the only people who
are benefiting from globalization and I
think a very telling example of this is
North Korea so we think of North Korea
is the ultimate kind of the Hermit
Kingdom the closed society and it is
those things does that mean that the
globalization has no impact on North
Korea well people don't have cell phones
and although that's starting to come in
now they have famines every 10 years or
so they have incredible oppressiveness
they don't get good quality TV like we
do but they do have some aspects of
globalization so for example they're the
number one producer globally of
counterfeit hundred-dollar bills they're
also currently supposed to be the number
one source of black market nuclear
technology and they're also a major
producer and exporter of opium and
heroin so in other words when you try to
close yourself off the only kind of
globalization you get is the deviant
kind so I just don't think this is going
to work I don't think it's a realistic
option I actually think that trying to
pull back is it going to make the
problem worse rather than better so the
other sort of extreme this people
sometimes propose when they hear this
kind of a lecture is well we should just
legalize it like you know get rid of get
rid of all this get rid of all these
barriers these are just silly moralism
as we should we should just you know
you know give up the ghost and let
everything let everything be permissible
and and get rid of this and I have to
say I have somewhat more sympathy with
this kind of view because at least it's
realistic about the economic incentives
that underpin the system but I also
think that this is sort of unrealistic
just as unrealistic as the first one is
about economics this is unrealistic
about the nature of people's social
systems as you know I quoted Durkheim
earlier and I have to do it again
societies are defined in large measure
by the set of things they prohibit and I
think most of us you know maybe we say
okay we think marijuana should be
legalized or maybe even cocaine and
heroin and but do really most of us
think that people parents should be
allowed to sell their children as sex
slaves or that you know northerners
should be allowed to dump their toxic
waste all over the global south or that
countries should be allowed to
completely rape their natural
environments just because they happen to
have some UN border drawn around this
particular plot of land I think most of
us probably feel there have to be limits
and there always will be in any event
even if you as an individual have
completely given up all moral limits so
I don't think that that's a particularly
realistic option I think the only thing
we can do is two things one is we can
make judicious choices the first thing
we have to do actually is we have to
recognize the structural nature of this
phenomenon and not try to run away from
it not try to think it's going to go
away or there this minor aberration in
the system we have to embrace the fact
that this is the reality of the system
and once we do that this forces us into
a series of not very pleasant but at
least quite clear choices we have to
decide what do we worry about more a
million people in jail for nonviolent
drug offenses or our moral inhibitions
about drug use a bloodbath in northern
Mexico or our moral inhibitions about
drug use our desire to see countries in
the global south be able to develop any
way they want and dumping of toxic
chemicals by northern countries and
allowing them to do that any way they
want these are not easy choices actually
I don't want to you know I think most of
us probably fall one way or another on
these things but these are not easy
choices and main point I would leave us
with at the end of this is that what
devian globalization tells us is that
these not easy choices are not going
away
we're going to have to confront them and
and stick with them in perpetuity thank
you very much
[Applause]
all right first question from Robin
Sloane where are you okay so if I was
gonna get into deviant globalization
which industry should I choose what's
the best balance of risk and reward
right now what's in the what's an
emerging market in this area and where
might I get a first mover advantage well
first of all I'd say that if you can if
you have their access to the resource
probably the finance side is where the
most the money is and we know that
bankers make most of money right so if
you can get into that that's probably
the best place to start I also think it
depends on what your personal risk
profile is you know if you've got a lot
of computer skills you can become a
computer computer hacker and that's
probably not very risky to you drug
dealing tends to have a lot of violence
with it but on the other hand that's
where a lot of the money is but at the
other day if I had to make a choice if
your goal is to make as much money as
possible it's always finance I see some
people leaving for the doors let's go
sit down here I read somewhere somebody
described me what you're doing is saying
that the overall the deviant global
economy seems to be growing faster than
the legitimate global economy is that
the case do you think I think it is I
mean I to go back to what I said earlier
I'm somewhat skeptical when I read any
particular set of numbers because of the
various interests people have in
obscuring the truth about those numbers
but all of the anecdotal evidence from
you know thousands of data points
collected across the globe suggests that
you know because the infrastructure of
globalization is increasing the overall
integration of the economy completely
for originally motivated by legitimate
economic opportunities licit economic
opportunities this is just creating a
greater opportunity for people without
moral qualms if you don't have the
regulatory barriers you're going to grow
faster and these are unregulated markets
primarily and so they will grow faster
it's it's basically a nama theory and as
I say it's supported by a thousand
anecdotal data
points so there's a lot of investors
supporting a legitimate economy or their
investors supporting this economy and
probably some people here would like to
know how to get into it well I you know
they're not personally my friends so I
don't I don't really know but yeah I
mean obviously if finance seers are
critical to they provide startup capital
of one store in another you know and
some of this is at a grassroots level I
have no doubt that some of those monies
that people are getting from Grameen
Bank are being used to set up and listen
industries if one of things that you
know we consider here in the West be
illicit whether it's setting up a
brothel or you know harvesting something
from the forest and bringing it to
market in Mumbai or what-have-you I mean
these are you know people in most of the
global South the distinction between
licit and illicit is not particularly
relevant they're just trying to make
money and survive any way they can and
if that means that they can make more
money in an illicit business they're
gonna go that way generally speaking we
make the distinction they don't are you
sure of that I mean here's a guy in some
sort of the grey economy informal
economy Islam and there's some
opportunity to do laundry and there's
some opportunity to sell drugs yeah and
they look exactly the same hammers there
are other stuff going well I mean is
there a mother in the picture saying
something is there a daughter and there
may in some cases be moral qualms that
are particular to those societies but my
guess is that for most people who come
from those kinds of environments the
choice a lot largely hinges on what
their alternative opportunities are and
also their personal preferences if
you're a little skinny guy you probably
don't want to become a thug in a gang
right whereas if you know if you feel
like you have other kinds of skills you
might pursue trying to get an education
or what-have-you but if the best options
that are available to you are the
illicit ones people are going to pursue
those opportunities questions from JT
burn hurt how does all this stuff moved
around or the deviant shipping
organizations there's something more
parasitic and integrated with legal
shipping that's a great question
so certainly a lot of this stuff is
moving through the intermodal shipping
system and I think you have to look
commodity by commodity so if you're
looking at a commodity that is
in itself legal but it may have been
harvested illegally then those things
typically there's some paperwork that's
done on the back end to bring these
things into a light economy so a stand
of timber in Burma gets cut down and
what you need to do is bring it across
the border into China say that it's
Chinese timber and then you can ship it
down to the ports and South China and
make it legitimate then you load it onto
the intermodal shipping system and you
ship it off to Europe or North America
or you turn it into furniture and China
itself but there you know the line at
some point there's this shift over from
the illicit to the listen with actually
illegal commodities like drugs for
example those things sometimes are
coming through the you know main in the
main transportation infrastructure so
there's drug mules who swallow swallow
you know condoms full of cocaine or
heroin and bring them through in their
body that's using obviously you know
regular commercial aircraft to bring the
drugs in there's other people who like
you know build submarines and ship those
things over there's people who flies
little airplanes fly by night things
there's people who bring it in on
suitcases so it varies a lot I think
that you know it depends on what the
particular commodity you're looking at
is this is the case that if you if the
nation say the US trying to keep drugs
out the squeezes off one place where it
comes in it just comes in through
another is that what happens yeah well
that metaphor is exactly right I mean
I've heard of this of squeezing the
balloon some of my clients a few years
ago I was trying to explain this exactly
metaphor to that me I said you can
decide probably where the drugs are
gonna flow more or less do you want it
to come through Mexico or through the
Caribbean but you can't decide whether
the drugs are going to flow they're
gonna flow you can if you spray crops in
Peru they're gonna grow them in Ecuador
and Bolivia right and you can't spray
the whole of the Andes it's too big
right so this actually raises really
important policy questions you can
decide who's going to benefit and who's
going to bleed and actually to me this
raises extremely disturbing questions
which is who's actually whose interest
is it to continue the drug war actually
I mean obviously the prison unions in
the state have a large interest in
keeping drugs be illegal and they Lobby
vociferously to prevent these things but
there's lots of other people the DEA is
budget depends entirely on the war on
drugs continuing you think the head of
the DEA wants to see his business
ended of course he doesn't write and so
there are this is classic libertarian
theory we're hearing here you know the
cops gotta keep a certain amount of
robbers that they can get don't get to
be cops I did quote Milton Friedman the
the slums overtime not all of them but
many of them become sort of gradually
the get infrastructure they get they
started participate in the regular
economies and people paid taxes and it
it legitimates overtime San Francisco
made that pass from the you know pretty
horrifying state of the town and the
gold rush into its safe on the streets
now is that something that goes on in
these domains sometimes I mean certainly
sometimes you can see marketplaces move
from illicit to listen example uh let me
think of some well I mean I you know you
can think it's a little bit of a
historical example I'm gonna invoke the
tea party but in the actual historical
sense here I apologize I mean what is it
that the tea parties were protesting
they were protesting a stamp tax and
part of the reason why they were
protesting this is because they were
bringing a lot of tea and a lot of rum
and a lot of molasses rather a lot of
molasses they were turning into rum and
they were doing this under cover of
darkness quite literally and the British
were trying to crack down after the
French and Indian War and they were
trying to get more revenues out of the
system and you know there was a
revolutionary uprising and the u.s.
became an independent country and then
these businesses were largely
legitimated and the people who had been
producing rum or in you know importing
tea became legitimate entrepreneurs and
the new colonial economy of the United
States of America why did they do that
why did they become legitimate when they
hadn't enjoyed being illegitimate with
the Brits well you know there were still
uprisings in the United States and there
in late in the late 18th century I mean
the whiskey rebellion was specifically
about people not wanting to have the
writ of Washington I mean the Brits
hadn't really been trying to control
western Pennsylvania
once the United States became an
independent country in the 1890s they
started trying to collect tax on whiskey
and this caused a direct uprising and
remind me what happened how did that
play out
well it's interesting Washington
President Washington actually personally
led the troops into battle this is the
only time the commander-in-chief's
actually ever personally led the troops
I didn't know little now the battle was
never joined Washington showed up in in
western Pennsylvania and when he showed
up with the cavalry that said the rebels
decided to stand down did he have moral
authority because he was local instead
of British or did he just have troops
that were gonna actually do it instead
one unhappy redcoats I think yeah I mean
I I don't know the story in great detail
but I think he had a great deal of moral
authority and Washington was considered
the most moral man in America and it's
also worth noting however just to give a
sense of the moral compass of the time
that he was the richest man in America
largest slave holder in America and one
of the tallest men in America he could
do true and he could do the broad jump
any broad jump longer than anybody else
that's right at that time in the world
right there so he was and he was he was
considered one of the best horsemen I
mean this was mattered in that time
period I mean he was one of the best
horsemen in America so he had a whole
series of things which were you know
quasi aristocratic and but he was also
considered a man of great personal
authority and this is one of the ways in
which he was able to legitimate a
colonial rebellion so I'm not sure this
completely answers your question that's
interesting there are other examples
though people who have you know been in
what generated a pile of cash from an
illegitimate business and use that to
start up a legitimate business so this
happens all the time for example in in
Thailand or many many people young women
leave the villages and go become
prostitutes for a few years and they
collect nest egg which allows them then
to set up a shop or find a husband or
set up a business that you know being a
hairdresser back in the village where
they came from
you know that's again not to you know
discount the tardiness of the distance
they have to go through to raise that
pile of cash but often that can be a
capital acquisition strategy and that's
at a grassroots level
you know there's a lot of businessmen
who try to go legitimate once they
acquire a large enough you know illicit
Empire there's definitely many people
who have done that over time so this is
something keeps pulling me back yeah
exactly
so it is it plays out that sounds like
it in you were sort of talking about
your in terms of policy when is making
individual decisions based on each of
these separate situations it's a
separate context and separate sequences
of events over time you know it's this
situation ripe to go legitimate if you
tried to do that too early you get in
trouble but if you're George Washington
showing up on a large horse you might
get away well I think this is a really
interesting question Stewart I don't
think it's really been studied in those
kinds of comparative terms people have
certainly written a lot about particular
cases where kind of a an illicit economy
undermines the state to the point where
the state becomes really chaotic and you
know to use the language I think is
misleading it becomes it looks like a
failed state but that's not always the
path right sometimes things go that way
and you get in a very chaotic and
violent situation typically that's
actually cuz the state is trying to
respond and then fails catastrophic way
and then D legitimates itself and that's
where you get failed states that's the
situation that you have in Congo today
that's the situation that happened in in
Somalia in the early 1990s but sometimes
it can go the other way that as you're
suggesting we're you know these elicit
uh you know illicit businesses can be a
way of raising capital which can then be
translated into legitimate businesses
and therefore provide kickstart capital
for you know other kinds of
entrepreneurship that we might not seen
as negative alight you mentioned a few
minutes ago your clients who exactly are
your clients
well monitor 360 is kind of spinoff of
global business Network and we focus
mainly on security and intelligence
clients in the US government I want to
say just a little more
I worked with him in this matter so it's
you know that it's not like I'm drawing
out something I don't know yeah I mean I
think one of the things is really
interesting and the reason why we
created a separate business unit apart
from gbn is that some of the people are
most interested in long-range thinking
our organizations like governments and
particularly the security elements of
governments it's not a coincidence that
the first part of the only part of the
last administration's government that
took climate change seriously was the
Defense Department if you really plan to
be around for 50 100 200 years then you
need to work with organizations that can
help you think about those kinds of
things and that's really what our
organization is about it's about helping
people think about the future in in
provocative and creative ways and you
know I think that there's you know those
kinds of organizations are particularly
interested in that sort of thing and
personally I like as I think you do are
working with intelligence community and
Department of Defense people because
they are highly educated they're highly
oriented to the globe and I get a sense
that they often know more than the State
Department people they the term national
security has great standing in the
public process and it's gotten blended
with the idea of global security
mmm-hmm in an interesting way and in
terms of what you're talking about
tonight how how does those fit each
other I'm not sure I know what you're
asking Stuart but um that's why I asked
it golda security national security
what's the relationship what's it have
to do with deviant globalization yeah so
I mean national security you know
there's some obvious ways in which the
stories I've been telling tonight have
particular implications for the
nation-state as a whole and the
nation-state is you know border security
military affairs could create demand for
military interventions in one place or
another
particularly if these economies go from
snafu to fubar then you know there may
be some demand for you know some kind of
military intervention so those are some
of the practical kinds of questions that
people in the military get to be
interested in
but a sort of global security level or
at a human security level there's been
this merging of and you know this talk
is in some sense a manifestation of that
in the last 15 years there's been an
emerging of the discourse of development
and the discourse of security and in
fact that you know the UN rather the
World Bank puts out an annual
development report along with the UN and
every year it's on a different topic I
think last year it was on transportation
infrastructure the year before that was
about agriculture the year before that
it was climate change this year it's on
development and security and sort of by
definition when the UN put the UN the
World Bank puts out something that is
the conventional wisdom and that means
that that topic has arrived
well I'd argue that the confluence of
security conversations and development
conversations has really been has really
become the dominant framework over the
last 10 years for thinking about
security in the global south and in fact
all of our counterinsurgency efforts
right now in in Afghanistan are rooted
in the notion that you can't possibly
stabilize the place unless you provide
them with some kind of development now
we can have some debates about whether
it's possible for the u.s. from afar to
create loyalty in a people for a state
that they've never in their entire
history of loyalty to but the notion
that that is what the objective ought to
be is certainly central to the thinking
of a lot of security planners in the
United States government today about the
emerging subject of cyber conflict well
that's another one right so here's
what's really interesting I mean bear in
mind I'm one of the co-organizers of the
hackers contractor day right yeah and
you know hackers that they can all like
sort of stuff and I've been sort of
horrified to see how that's gone
downhill on some respect since my day
I think you know there's some people who
might think that's gone way up hill I
don't know I mean they're making more
money on it that's for sure as the you
know this none of this information
should be free stuff no well that's how
do I get into computer and steal all
your power and all your model it's
certainly there's a lot of commercials
there's a lot of commercial hacking it
used to be for fun and games or maybe
for mischief that was primarily
motivating hacking 10-15 years ago
what's really changed is that the the
center of gravity for the global hacking
industry is really focused as you say on
money making but what's really
interesting from a security perspective
on this is that there's actually been
emerging here in the business world of
the hacking for profit and hacking for
nationalist reasons and I'll give you a
specific a couple of examples from where
these are not people in Memphis I think
we're know so these are well it's always
hard to know where exactly behind which
mirror which particular man is but
certainly the botnets
that are being used to run denial of
service attacks in places like Georgia
during the conflict in August 2008 or in
Estonia in the spring of 2007 those
botnets had been around for a while
serving commercial spam and running
denial of service for extortion reasons
and these were being run apparently by
Russian criminal hacker organizations
and then when the wars went well it was
just a cyber war in the case of Estonia
and it was actually a hot war in the
case of Georgia when these things broke
out actually the cyber war began before
any shots were fired in the case of
Georgia so these same botnets that had
been used for criminal purposes were
then redeployed to target enemies of the
Soviet of the Russian state by command
of the Russian state well nobody really
knows nobody knows well somebody knows
but I don't know
yeah.the you follow motivations upstream
on things like that what's I mean we had
Daniel Suarez here a year ago or so
talking about botnets what's the scale
of botnets going on no I mean well the
Zeus botnet which is currently still
growing it's not clear who's commanding
it hasn't been deployed to do anything
yet I think has six million zombies
zombie fide computers in it right now
some of them in owned by people in this
room I mean how spread is well you know
six million computers I don't know how
many computers are on the world but you
know it's probably fairly you're
probably getting close to 1% of all the
computers in the world
so just statistically it's probably
several of you that are infected just in
case you were thinking this was all of
us stuff happens to other people you
know I think we're gonna have to wrap up
because this clearly it's gonna go on a
long way but take a little further where
you were going with the not just what do
we do about it but you've watched as an
historian I'll ask you to do the
forbidden thing for historians which is
you know take the stuff that you're
observing for the last couple decades
and project a couple decades and you
know if you want to do a scenario or two
go for it but how might this play out
well I mean I think a lot of it depends
on how states react to these things and
I think that we've been talking about
several different scenarios I think many
of which are likely to play out in
different locales so I think that in
some places
devian globalization will provide
legitimate opportunities for many people
to get out of poverty and you know
that's all to the good whether it means
getting out of the country they're in
and traveling to somewhere in the global
north or starting some kind of a deviant
business and making some money on it
there's a lot of people who are gonna
you know basically benefit from this
kind of behavior now there'll be lots of
people who are outraged by this whether
it's people emptying the sea of tuna or
chopping down the last stand of old
growth in Burma or what-have-you but you
know somebody will have a you know nice
sushi dinner here in San Francisco or a
nice hardwood floor and as they walk
across it at night and they probably
won't think too much about that so you
know you know I think that there's gonna
be benefits of that sort that come out
of this I also think that it's almost
inevitable
because it's already happening that in
many cases visa illicit flows when they
grow when they so there's a specific
scenario that I think often leads to
really bad political outcomes violent
political outcomes and that is when a
new resource stream comes online so if a
new resource stream which can be
targeted by deviant entrepreneurs comes
online so if there's this it's at the
start of a methamphetamine epidemic in a
particular country that typically
there's a lot of violence associated
with it because the markets are
uncertain at that point people are
trying to carve out spaces you don't
have a dominant player yet that's
typically where you end up with a
situation we have a lot of violence and
a lot of and a lot of unpleasantness
similarly if there's a sudden change in
the nature of the regulations which are
being applied to those particular
deviant industries that's also a
situation where because it'll you know
upset the market equilibrium which the
players have established is likely to
particularly fount of money involved is
very large lead to a lot of violent
conflict around these things which if
the state is not careful can actually
implode the state so it can sort of
boomerang back on the state that's
trying to crack down on this stuff and
and actually undermine the state's
institutions I think it's a it's a not
insignificant risk that we face in in
Mexico right now are you saying do
nothing suddenly that's that's sort of
what emerge from that well I think that
you know states don't always have
autonomy in their choices right I mean
the Mexican state can't you know do deal
very easily with the drug lords at this
point I think that that's probably
what's going to end up happening in
Mexico that's probably the likely
endgame in Mexico but if that's not the
endgame as long as there's drug demand
in this country there's gonna be people
who want to bring it north and you know
there's drug demand and drug prohibition
in this country people want to bring it
north there's gonna be people gonna
fight about that as long as the state
keeps fighting with them that's probably
gonna work out worse for the Mexican
state then it's gonna work out for the
drug dealers now these people may have
short lifespans but there's always
somebody else ready to step up to the
plate and organize these things I mean
the one thing we learned it from
Colombia in the late 1980s and early
1990s is even if you decapitate the
Capo's in these situations that does not
make the situation go away in fact it
from an intelligence perspective it
often makes the problem worse instead of
having three guy
you need to track you now have 50 guys
you need to track me you don't know who
they are right right so that actually
can often make the problem worse there
was more violence in Colombia in the
1990s and there was in the 1980s when it
was run by a few guys on the other hand
when Peru decapitated the guy who was
head of the Shining Path that was the
end of the Shining Path that's because
those guys were traditional political
revolutionaries they wanted to take over
the state so in that case you can go
after these guys don't have an ongoing
set of you know if you can get rid of
the ideological entrepreneurs you can
actually win those kinds of wars
potentially now you know of course
there's still all the social oppression
in the countryside in in Peru which was
fomenting this and now actually The
Shining Path guys are back and now
they're drug dealers so yeah that keeps
happening doesn't the IRA and the thing
after thing does that and then
presumably something comes after that
but so okay everybody knows about
deviant globalization thanks to your
book a year from now and other attention
gets paid by governments and so on and
and that there's this other lumpy world
non free money in the world right and
we're aware of it and we're doing this
judicious choosing a various things is
it changed the game to be aware of it
because my sense is for example when Rob
North said there's a billion people in
slums and they're actually not bad
people who are not all that bad off
trying to get out of poverty in there
they're succeeding and that becomes part
of this whole story by the way is a
whole lot of the world coming up are
they coming up through a period where
this is very tempting but as things get
better will it then get will will this
start to reduce is there a demographic
transition like having fewer children is
there less deviant globalization as
people get well enough off Emily not
just the the rich robin hood's yeah I
don't know I haven't thought about that
I'm sorry going along because I I'm not
sure where we go now and no my guess is
that people get richer they moved from
the supply side to the demand side
[Laughter]
we're done that solves that thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you